you said you were going to do something
you didn't do I'm retiring
we're good I gave up like you know what
it's not working out I gave up
there is this belief that um Giselle
gave Tom an ultimate a mere football
she very clearly and very strongly
pushes back on that narrative and says
but it's not true marriages aren't built
or broken
with a snap of a finger over one season
vanity fairs Michelle Ruiz spent two
emotional days in Costa Rica with the
supermodel who uses these words to
describe the implosion of her 13-year
marriage a death and a rebirth tough
heartbreaking she was mourning something
that was clearly over in any way does
she blame herself for this breakup she
said she can only do so much the other
person has to meet you in the middle and
she didn't feel like Tom and her in the
middle
I think that was the implication yeah
Gisele and Tom are co-parenting three
kids including eldest Jack whose mom is
Tom's ex Bridget Moynihan remember Tom
found out about the pregnancy shortly
after he and Gisele started dating
that experience co-parenting with
Bridget is now kind of informing how how
Giselle treats co-parenting with Tom
they're on the same team and they're
really really putting their children's
interests forward
since her divorce Giselle has been seen
regularly in Costa Rica with Jiu Jitsu
instructor joaquim balange then came a
headline claiming she's seeing 55 year
old billionaire Jeffrey sopher AKA Tom's
friend the 42 year old tells Vanity Fair
out April 4th quote I have zero
relationship with him in any way I
wouldn't be with this guy he's old
Gisele was really devastated by by that
report and she said as part of a
campaign of planting negative stories
about her to sort of make her look bad
would that campaign include her Jiu
Jitsu instructor
we talked about various people who she
says she's not dating but she does speak
really really highly of Joachim as a
force a force of good in her life and
her Children's Life Next for Giselle a
life in Costa Rica
she says if she could live there full
time she would she hopes to live there
full time eventually do you think that
in the future she will date I do think
that she is a really family-oriented
person of devoted mother so I don't
think that she would take that likely
you look cute
foreign